vote n'est pas vraiment une surprise
c'est en fait la continuation logique de
la réforme constitutionnelle voulue par
vladimir poutine annoncé en janvier 2020
est votée l'été dernier d'après la
chambre haute du parlement russe cette
nouvelle loi entend dorénavant mettre en
conformité la législation électorale
avec les nouvelles normes de la
constitution et pour les parlementaires
qui ont voté ce texte en troisième
lecture
c'est une question de cohérence nous
n'avons rejeter aucun amendement dans ce
projet de loi l'ensemble des amendements
soumis au comité ont été examinés et
inclus dans le tableau numéro à 1,2610
ne réussit pas dire jantes au fond du
projet de loi
la faction russie unie soutient son
adoption puisque notre faction assume
ses responsabilités rich lee chin et
mats annales et ne cherche pas de raison
et de prétextes émotionnels pour
échapper à ses responsabilités
je veux dire que ce projet de loi
contribuer à la résolution de problèmes
majeurs
ce projet de loi élimine l'incertitude
juridique
ce projet de loi assure la
synchronisation des normes de la loi
électorale
concrètement c'est un amendement de
cette loi qui est particulièrement
commenté un amendement qui permet au
président en exercice a de nouveau se
présenter et donc briguer deux mandats
supplémentaires alors que la loi jusque
maintenant obligés vladimir poutine à se
retirer à la fin de son mandat actuel
c'est-à-dire en 2024 et bien dans le
cadre de cette nouvelle loi
il peut désormais potentiellement rester
au pouvoir jusqu'en 2036 reste à savoir
quels sont les projets de vladimir
poutine
aujourd'hui âgé de 68 ans